[Music]
to describe the musical style of maurice
ravel is kind of like describing a quilt
that's meticulously sewn together and
made up of a mixture of colors and
fabrics from all around the world and
from different time periods Ravel was a
French composer who was born in 1875 to
a Swiss father and a basque mother and
lived until 1937 he's widely recognized
as one of the greatest composers of
classical music and is often associated
with the impressionistic period similar
to Impressionism in the visual arts at
the time the music from this movement
focused on conveying an atmosphere and
subtle imprints of emotions rather than
carrying excessive or exaggerated
expression something that you'd find
more so in romantic music although this
description helps organize music history
for us it only goes so far
in Ravel's case so much of his music
actually sits very far from the commonly
accepted descriptions of impressionistic
music in other words Ravel's music is
very French and impressionistic but it's
not exactly all watery and blurry not
that that's what Impressionism is about
but to speak of it generally
[Music]
to start off looking at some areas of
inspiration evident in Ravel's music can
give us a better idea of his style we
find a lot of elements of baroque and
Renaissance music such as counterpoint
strict forms elaborate yet poised
ornamentation and symmetry in his music
in other words for Val borrows a lot of
things from composers that came many
years and centuries before him this
makes his music sound more organized and
reserved in many ways
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
influences from distinct cultures from
all around the world are also present in
his music for example these include the
use of extended harmonies and complex
rhythms from American jazz and the blues
dance rhythms scales and forms from folk
music originating from France Spain
Russia and Italy among many other
countries and sonorities from indonesian
gamelan music and music from other parts
of asia
in other words revels music is quite
multicultural emerging from this mixture
of qualities are also key elements of
revels personal voice which is like a
combination of childlike simplicity
flamboyant virtuosity innovative
movement of harmony strict forms and
symmetrical proportions mechanical
precision of rhythmic and melodic ideas
and an imaginative palette of musical
textures in other words revels music
makes me imagine a children's story
perhaps about a group of friends maybe a
nostalgic french person a shy jazz
musician and a spanish dancer all
traveling on an asian wooden boat to
cross the river to enter a Louisville
castle where they come across a carnival
and all get lost but then find a village
of people huddled around a campfire that
serve them warm soup now following the
tradition of these how to sound like
videos where I honor the composer's
birthday let's go directly to the piano
and look at how all of these things
might translate into music Ravel is very
ambiguous that's why I like him
all right so let's focus we have
obviously the melody
[Music]
happy birthday I want to fragment the
melody so that the beginning just really
focuses on these two pairs I think there
needs to be a little more structure and
a little more momentum also I'm choosing
a closer voicing so all these notes are
pretty close together versus wider any
spacing that has these rubs I'm trying
to go for something with a waltz like
quality but this is a little too obvious
when Ravel makes something sweet it has
a little undertone of something
nostalgic no this is a little too suave
[Music]
okay so that wraps up that section
moving on Ravel has a lot of sections
where you have one space and then you go
to another place and you come back then
you go back this sort of back and forth
thing we need something otherworldly
okay I like that
this is a little too mushy maybe it's
time for another flourish so something
kind of like how water spews out
somewhere we need we need more more
happening some more bubbles in the water
[Music]
okay so we have enough bubbles and
enough splashes
[Music]
now we need to return to somewhere where
it's delicate
so even when something is extremely
delicate in Ravel's music there's always
something very solid about it something
that just holds everything together
almost like a very delicate flower but
frozen inside a geometric a perfectly
shaped geometric block of ice so
something like this
is a little too loose
okay
we're gonna
switch that node around a lot of times
you find cords that need to resolve like
a dominant seventh chord but instead of
actually resolving
maybe whole string
several together and just keep going
slightly heartbroken yes okay so so
something like this where I imagine just
more lacing this I'm gonna have to
practice this later but
[Music]
it's almost like seeing something lit in
a way where you're not quite sure
whether it's getting darker or getting
lighter
okay this is a little Debussy
[Music]
maybe just
whoops
okay I'm going to borrow from some
things that I learned from doing that
list video where we're gonna have to use
both right and left hand for the melody
here
[Music]
a little tremolo that's interlocked
either that or maybe both but there's
just one more little leaf that kind of
blows in the air at the end okay I have
enough notes now to practice this and
while I do that over the next few days
I'll probably have a better idea of what
things I want to keep and I'll have some
adjustments made along the way so I'll
check in with you in a few days okay so
on second thought right there I feel
like it's a little too Christmasy a
little yeah a little Christmasy so I'm
going to change that a little bit if I
can maybe it's too late
maybe I'll just I'll just thin it out a
little bit
and play it in a matter-of-fact way so
not give it too much attention or too
much sweetness yet now that we've worked
out the arrangement we must talk about
how it's going to be played because that
is a huge part of it for example just
the opening if I played this with a
different type of articulation that
would be a little more his Spanish voice
so less pedal doesn't really work as
well so just having enough pedal and a
certain kind of uniformity to the sound
but also with a little bit of focus on
the tops maybe part like this outlining
the top and the octave so that the sound
has a little bit of focus in a place
like this it helps to keep your fingers
pretty limp so that they're really
relaxed and it's almost as if they're
hanging from your wrists but I mean
obviously I'm exaggerating here but
keeping it loose allows you to play with
a little more delicate touch regarding
time and pacing I'm going to be using as
little rubato as possible so nothing too
exaggerated in terms of pushing and
pulling the time so much for example
something like this
[Music]
is with a lot of rubato so instead I'm
going to keep it much more regular and
conservative in terms of taking too much
time in places
[Music]
okay I think I'm ready to record
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that is all for now thank you so much
for watching and a special thank you to
my patrons on patreon